[Music]
August 8 1940 and the battle for Britain
is on thirty enemy air part of the
channel
I knew where it would become one of the
most significant battles of the Second
World War
advancing through Europe Nazi Germany
set its sights on the British Isles
phase one knock out the Royal Air Force
and its bases get control of the air and
the sea lanes across the channel
outnumbered and outgunned it looked like
British fighters wouldn't stand a chance
against the superior Luftwaffe but they
had a technology that would give them an
edge
here's how Britain's hunt for a death
ray gave us radar in 2017 something
incredible happened not a single
passenger jet was involved in a fatal
accident despite a record for
billionaire passenger journeys being
made skies have never been so busy the
2017 was the safest year in commercial
aviation in fact you're much more at
risk on the way to the airport according
to a Harvard study the odds of being
killed in a car crash a one in 5,000
your odds of death in a plane crash a 1
in 11 million how aircraft avoid midair
collisions is thanks to radar but it all
started with the search for a deadly
weapon row back to 1935 war was looming
and there were rumors Germany had a
weapon capable of wiping out whole towns
the British government feared an aerial
invasion and wanted a Death Ray that
could knock German planes out of the sky
the Air Ministry approached electrical
engineer Robert watson-watt watson-watt
had worked for the Meteorological Office
where he experimented using radio waves
to locate thunderstorms he quickly
determined a Death Ray was practically
impossible to build but leaning on their
previous work in firing radio waves at
targets they offered an alternative to
the death ray his memo to the ministry
was titled the detection of aircraft by
radio methods two weeks later the team
successfully used a radio transmitter to
detect a circling raf bomber eight miles
away radio detection and ranging radar
was born the team quickly extended the
range of radar up to a hundred miles
they work fast the fear of imminent
attack was never far from their minds by
the outbreak of war in 1939 the team had
built 19 radar stations on Britain's
south and east coasts with over 50 built
by 1945 this system of stations became
known as chain home as well as detecting
enemy aircraft its centralized radar
reports to operators who could quickly
scramble fighter crews to into
set the enemy teams from Germany Japan
and the US were all working on their own
radar systems but the UK's was the most
advanced British scientists developed
something called a cavity magnetron
improving on a German idea and then
shared it with allies in the u.s. the
technology reduced the size of radar
devices meaning they could be installed
in night fighters anti-submarine
aircraft and escort ships planes were
given transponders devices that send and
receive radio signals which would help
them identify enemy and friendly planes
increasingly useful when vision was poor
the radar could only do so much the Nazi
struck Britain with all their might they
leveled thousands upon thousands of
homes and damaged millions of others
they killed more than 40,000 men women
and children without radar it might have
been much worse
the Nazis never landed on British soil
after the war air travel exploded
especially in the u.s. many other water
tested devices are incorporated in the
luxury air liner which ushered in a new
era in American aviation but there are
few regulations and many airports didn't
even install radar see and be seen was
the main rule of thumb that would
quickly change after June 30th 1956 128
people died following a collision
between two Airlines over the Grand
Canyon investigators determined the
pilots couldn't see each other due to
cloudy conditions as the public learned
of the crude nature of air traffic
control pressure mounted on Congress to
make air travel safer a year later
President Eisenhower signing the Airways
Modernization Act which improved
monitoring of planes from takeoff to
landing using transponders based on
those developed during the Battle of
Britain u.s. airlines devised a
compulsory system that would become
industry standard known as t casts the
traffic collision avoidance system if a
plane entered another's airspace it
would automatically issue a command to
maneuver climb climb be burned
be burned today radar systems work in
conjunction to paint a complete and
detailed picture of the skies
using transponders to identify planes
their positions and their altitude air
traffic control on the ground tracks
speed and direction by monitoring
transmissions as the controllers say the
best way to fly is in radar County the
GPS has been added to the equation too
because once an aircraft is out at sea
radar coverage fades
planes can now fly for hours with
precise navigation so events like the
disappearance of Malaysian Airways
flight mh370 and 2014 undoubtedly add to
the fears we have a flying but when
looked at in context such accidents are
extremely rare thanks to the giant leaps
made in safety galvanized all those
years ago by the Battle of Britain
you
you